Ghostbusters Frozen Empire picks up
right where the last installment of the
franchise Ghostbusters afterlife left
off only this time the gang is back in
New York City which is where the
original installment began so it's new
but also has a throwback vibe to it the
acting core is Finn wolfard Mckenna
Grace Carrie and Paul Rudd they
have to save New York and presumably the
world from a ghostly force that
literally scares people to death and
something tells me they'll be making a
lot of funny jokes as they do it it
arrives on March 29th these two
heavyweights are back and looking to get
into some trouble on April 12th but
before you assume it's just them
fighting from the opening bell it
appears they are actually allies in this
one at least to start they apparently
find out about something from
underground that will threaten Earth's
survival you know no biggie